okay I'm back what how did I die hmm
what happened to me oh you got grenades
oh I did not get grenades I gotta show
you what I discovered it's [ __ ]
awesome okay let's I start I did not
kill us
uh-huh I caused us to be killed but I
did not do it okay alright so so okay so
we're just hanging out yeah and I was
like aha he talks when you shoot him
uh-huh
right right watch this geez why am I
watching this hang on it's coming my
balls come on [ __ ] I'm waiting
for this oh my god your arm blew off my
arm down I was bleeding on oh hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to blood and bacon with Bob
so hi Bob everybody
good I I actually I'm not lying
I love this game this I can't wait for
people to see the footage of me
accidentally actually discovering that
Easter egg we needed there was like an
electrical box yeah over here
electric fence oh go in there
smelly won't kill me okay you want it
you want me to do the thing oh yeah
that's right okay needs nice I wonder if
it kills me if I walk through it
oh I got it doesn't why why is that okay
alright we gotta get to the next level
there's 30 days in this game we want
people want to see progress people want
to see us to make it through this game
and do it well with skill that is not
why people watch my videos I can say
that with authority okay that's
absolutely not what people expect from
me oh my god is he gonna kill us for the
flashlights okay I highly doubt that do
something you [ __ ] he's not there's
no way you go kill the pig zombie so we
can progress I'll just keep doing this
okay alright then
by the way also there's gonna be no pigs
until you get out of here so you might
as well carry on with this mission oh my
god it's [ __ ] pitch-black out there
yeah it's 9:00 now okay but what he
would just just grenades on us for
anything that we did ever I mean that
was what are some of these are described
distract them to distract him oh just
kill them all hell yeah oh oh oh oh my
god oh good what just oh jeez oh god
what rumbled to nothing
whoo I got an explosion okay we got to
keep like he said we got to keep about
almost got it wait what I'm keeping a
body part in the air whoa
ooh boy Oh Oh almost there almost there
it's too high
oh yeah fireworks do you see what no
where is that it's up in the air I did
it I did it by shooting body parts up in
the air I see new weapon okay well how'd
you get a body part up in the air you
got to shoot it you guys shoot a piece
of it you got to get a piece that's you
peace okay
make sure your bullets full of ammo or a
gun whatever oh no mmm make sure you're
full of bullet ammo okay then just kind
of like Boop got it up oh oh Jesus it's
harder than I thought how yeah how many
times you have to do it I can only get a
few before like gets away the [ __ ] far
away there's like a counter you gotta
like I forget how I did it like it must
have been a better body part than this
like the head maybe yeah yeah that's it
the head works better so you just got to
get it up and then there's like a
counter that starts oh yeah I saw that
got this one I'm on it I'm on it I'm on
it
almost there wait it's taking more than
the last time yeah yeah this this world
is weird but also did you notice that
that green silo in the distance over
there with the mounds on the side of its
penis
[Music]
there's something at the top of it
there's a key at the top of it get up
there a good question that's not a thing
you can do okay okay it's got to be a
lega can you shoot the thing off the top
uh doubt it there's a platform there so
obviously there's got to be like a
weapon that can rock it jump or
something that would make rockets oh wow
rocket jump so like my mind went to
rockets okay I'm gonna talk to the guy
what tomorrow's gonna be a day that you
don't want to miss he said we should use
that grounder you gotta use that
grounder don't get on Grindr find local
singles in your area with grinder
grinder
you gotta get the farmers only version
of grinder Posse way whoa my god is this
thing I have unlimited ammo oh my god it
does what it needs no reef whoa this is
amazing I want this this is the best gun
ever
oh also we get grenades now apparently
Rambo style What did he say Rambo style
he said he he put explosive ammo and all
the weapons or something oh really wait
how do I use the grenade one the one
button whoa oh my god oh god oh god this
is revenge day
is that why oh yeah these don't need
reload even the AKS like this the non
reloading revolver Oh
oh my god this is outstanding this is
next-level Gor this is uh where's the
other army its it revenge day comes once
a week oh boy does it ever wait I wonder
if we can I'm gonna chop down the silo
by shooting it that's a good idea
I'm sure that'll work maybe I got a
shoot uh shoot a pig peace up there
wait there's no there's no ki up there
anymore wha
was it only available that day no how
were we supposed to I don't know this
Martian why don't you know this [ __ ] I'm
an idiot
I didn't finish engineering school
that's why is that what you wanted to
hear
I actually was fishing for that yeah
well you got what you wanted
are you ready here first everybody
markiplier is an idiot whoa I'm getting
a sick combo on this thing with no
reload required B shoot something up
into the air situation is pretty easy
I'm helping I'm helping I'm helping it
literally just hold down left mouse on
the a K and sort of wave at it like I'm
not even really aiming at it and I'm
still getting hits on it no I'm doing it
I'm also helping we're work together on
this oh it's probably mostly you then
because I'm seriously like not even
really aiming that much well I'm well I
play to win so you need to get your game
together there we go all right let's get
to the next day yes that is a new world
record so you are aware of the pitchfork
yeah well I would be shocked if he
wasn't I mean he just sort of it's just
that's how it is so you know I just
figured he looks down like why am I on a
wall Oh God here
oh no and then he instantly dies like he
forgot he was supposed to die whoa check
out the reload action on this revolver
okay I don't know why I expect me just
get a side action
Oh I create bullets yeah hey hey you
like you like my gun but you do are you
doing these interactions more cinematic
hey hey there's a way out of this all
right I'm already dead so I feel like
this is kind of a lose-lose way so if I
do this blood and then just grenades at
me ooh dude whoa what what there was a
there's a Dark Souls praise the Sun
symbol but I love it I'm gonna walk
slowly around as he's his head tracks me
around this bharden Creek Lee well
singing there's also there's also a
skull up here I don't know what it's for
but there's an outline of a skull up
there they're the praises something was
up there or we got it this next round we
got to take a careful look around this
place because there's some secrets out
here and oh boy alright cuz I push the
button I shot the button I'm gonna go
turn the electric fence on before they
all start I'm gonna gather him I'm gonna
gather him up I got him don't worry I'm
black eye mask blasting all of them
don't worry last him I got him alright
I'm not there yet hang on it's fine
there we go that's some fried piggies
there see these ashen oh my god no
they're not so we need I need health
drink some water they seem to be doing a
lot more damage than they have been if
I'm a skeleton and drinking this water
gave you your arms back all the way
shouldn't this water like bring me back
to life
theoretically speaking but I'm assuming
it assumes that you're not dead
considering you're walking around so the
water is making assumptions about me and
that's why it's racist it's a very
judgmental water to be honest I don't
want to scare you but I think things are
gonna get a little bit more tough on you
oh start crying oh oh geez things are
gonna get more tough on us did you talk
to him yeah I talked to him okay oh why
were you doing something I was just
looking around I thought we were geez
I'm an idiot I apologize I for
oh Jesus what is it I don't know it's
big oh my god they're big oh they're big
oh they got big hoja last load they do
another don't you just dud
yeah they don't ask load whoa for how
big they are they [ __ ] come out of
nowhere yeah that was a biggie piggy
holy [ __ ] well why did I wander away
from the health water I'm gonna I'm
gonna try to shove one of these big uns
inside oh my god they do a splode yeah
oh okay okay
oh boy you should come get some liquid
I'm okay
oh my god I'm not okay how am i dying
what I was just dying help me I'm coming
I the pig was dead and I was pushing it
and it was just like ooh you're doing no
well maybe maybe maybe I was trying to
push him into the thing is it like if
you touch the tusks when you're pushing
it it hurts you Oh what whoa Oh what
whoa that is weird like if you touch
them on the front it hurts you well
that's not what I wanted I got grenade
Sorry Sorry
okay I'm gonna look around whoa what oh
there was another Sun symbol over here
just but it doesn't do anything if you
shoot it maybe it doesn't work because
the other Sun symbol was already shot I
wanna know how the pigs oh there's
another Sun symbol in here too
oh you did it wow I can't believe you
found that target okay this is a game of
many mysteries and also some drugs yeah
so why didn't this one work it bounced
real hard okay so there's got to be a
bunch of like hidden symbols like that
right right yeah sure yeah okay I can't
find anything whoa what just went flying
in the air oh is that you a little pig
leg okay all right if we want to find
secrets I guess we could read a guide
now that's for jerks okay are you gonna
find things I'm gonna trigger the next
trigger me ready don't do it okay
apparently we're gonna see something
completely new tomorrow like Pig zombies
yeah we'll use my psychopathic powers to
get that door for you I don't think
those were the right words let me use my
that's offensive that's really offensive
what's a psychopathic people yeah don't
they have worse problems than me making
it out of touch joke about them being
Psychopaths no what is happening what
did I get 50% of my health why the heck
can I kill these butterflies cuz oh hey
yeah there's little pigs it's a little
big they keep running in and out of my
line of sight as like out of the math oh
it's little pigs didn't heed little pig
oh jeez whoa oh they're so fast
but they're weak well Jesus they're
getting faster did he get faster than
leicester army [ __ ] I don't know but I'm
hurting oh my god oh god okay thank you
right there
Tromp trying man try it oh we're done I
guess oh sweet all right let's get
through day ten I bet there's a boss at
day ten
hopefully by the way that son on the
little red building it just made a sound
when you hit it okay
we haven't been absolutely been using
only my pistol for almost this entire
thing I mean that revolvers pretty good
nice cocking action on it it's a great
cocking action quite a cat mark can we
close it or could we undo whatever you
do not think we can oh wow oh geez
forget holy [ __ ]
jeez oh wait wait stop bro stop you
don't know nothing right well this seems
bad uh what if you all stay in here or
you stay in here one of us like peek out
oh my god oh my god its head follows you
oh my god wait what just gonna keep on
talking break myself my big fat head do
you shoot me
what oh god it'll okay hey it's Abbas
it's a bum percent illusion he's
invisible now hold on [ __ ] oh my god
this is Dara mark mark stay stay close
to me all right go to the center
go to the center Lua to the center yeah
I'll you why does that pig sound like
the farmer no okay he's coming to me get
ready with the electrical he's coming to
me all right tell me what tell me what
so no no no no oh geez I'm going okay
that was good though got rid of the
smaller pigs I'm gonna try them lorem
here I'll stay here
oh he was right there dude
did I get him no you didn't get him
lighten them up keep lighting them up we
can see where he is when the electric
fence is gigging cooing are you hurt you
all right come toward to you where's
comfort me he's close to the middle I am
riding him out and drawing drawn a
circle around the house okay he's coming
to me
we only get so many uses of it for night
and you float whoa
if you shoot him in the ass his ass does
something always got like electric [ __ ]
his ass
whoa that's game oh he's doing something
oh so angry his ass got blasted off what
he's healing oh very scary very scary
very scary you need to shoot his ass
bone yeah his big ass I'm gonna get more
ammo it's some grenades or something
okay all right xxxxX
okay grenade I'm down I'm down I'm down
all right I had to draw him away
oh he's nothing but hitting me on the
ground oh jeez hey Thank You Fred I'm
gonna go
we got full health nice okay I got
getting her dad's I'm getting grenades
good grades huh dick oh I missed on that
one
lighten up his ass good whoa that ass
blasting me as a damage oh yeah blast
him right knee is coming hmm I'm gonna
melody yeah he needs to clean himself by
pressing the T button are you it are you
at health right now yeah I'm healing up
ooh never mind he's right here Oh oh my
god he did his thing okay I got a get
I'm gonna get more ammo I'm healing up
we need a lot more we should have been
feel like a pistol yeah we should have
been feelin this thing up because whoo
hello oh jeez
because it like has a reservoir of blood
from the previous rounds or something oh
so it's like filled up all the way right
now
oh geez he lost more pieces of himself
but he's really going after me I gotta
go heal him I can't believe strategy is
a part of this this game is amazing by
the way
come here you [ __ ] oh you can
only ask blasting with your pistol
no the the the other gun works I believe
I'm not getting any ass blaster shots
with my a-game well Amy oh no it's just
not working well it's just not working
right now oh I think he has a new ass
blasting point cuz he lost something in
the horse oh yeah oh and he's done he's
done he's done is he no wait yes yeah
okay can we get him into the grinder no
yeah I bet we can break like part of him
off though yeah it's gonna really wail
on that spine there or maybe not maybe
this is just a satisfaction thing
yeah that's not where that's not working
alright so that was great we did it we
beat the boss
and that's only day ten game completed
game not completed yeah but maybe our
playthrough there's completed for now
that's one more let us know
because this game is wild but thank you
everybody so much for watching thanks
Bob for being here any wise words are
scary yeah nope stay down here